joining me now with full analysis are
Fox News medical contributor Dr Nicole
Sapphire former Bill Clinton advisor but
we forgive you Doug Schoen and Princeton
University political scientist Lauren
Wright Doug let me let me start with you
because I actually worked on the Clinton
campaign in 92. so I'm gonna you know I
I you might poke me back here but you
know we're looking at some things that
look very familiar to us from 2016 and
we know about the numbers then uh we
didn't have as much information
necessarily about Joe Biden but isn't
the other issue though also the fact
that it might not be Joe Biden it
wouldn't it be smart for for Trump and
for the American people to consider this
might be a race that we don't expect
well it's possible Tammy but everything
I'm hearing publicly and privately tells
me that Joe Biden wants to run and as of
this moment will be the candidate that
being said elections tend to be
referenda on the incumbent and Joe
Biden's numbers is I think you know
Tammy are at or below 40 percent and
Below 35 on the economy so Trump has a
narrow lead in The Real Clear Politics
averages and the scenario you paint of
him winning as the lesser of two evils
is certainly possible given the
administration's ratings and where we
stand now yeah I personally don't see
them as the lesser of two evils a lot of
Americans will though and you're going
to make a decision it's going to be
based on I think who's going to do the
best job in this case Lauren great to
see you you know when we think about out
the science of a political campaign
Trump surprised everyone in 16. he was
not an unknown but he was in this
environment he now is known and we know
what he accomplished Joe Biden is not
what he presented himself to be in 2020
he's clearly very different than what
people expected would you think that
that's going to affect people do people
feel like maybe they were tricked when
they voted in 2020
well look it was a big unknown in 2016
and that was Trump's benefit in 2020
which I think is more relevant Trump had
all of the trappings of an incumbent
president he had all of those tools even
more visibility than when he ran as a
celebrity and he couldn't get the job
done and so I think Trump is perhaps the
only Republican that Biden can soundly
beat and these other candidates I just
don't see getting to the threshold RFK
while I would love to see him debate
Biden as a political junkie isn't
anywhere near the threshold he'd need to
be and the DNC said they're not letting
him on the debate stage Marianne
Williamson you know Oprah's spiritual
advisor I don't think she's gonna get it
over the line and we're forgetting the
fact that Biden's own vice president
Harris is not even part of the
conversation because she's very
vulnerable and very unpopular and so who
would it be someone he either beat in
2020 I don't know but Trump's the
weakest person he's got that's who
Democrats are sincerely hoping will be
the nominee and likely will be yeah
Dr Nicole I think that they also thought
he was particularly weak uh in 2016. he
wasn't taken seriously there's always
been an underestimation of him the
difference now I think though is that
Joe Biden hid in the basement we were we
were not aware necessarily of his
cognitive situation we now have seen
that every day at least when he's out
and about do you think that's a factor
that Americans are looking at with the
president which we which we really he
literally was hidden away from us I
don't think that's going to work this
time and I think the American people are
concerned and even the Democrats I think
a majority don't want him to run again
will that be a factor
well Tammy listen it was an easy
campaign from his basement during the
pandemic and it seems to be he's doing
the same method now we're not seeing him
much and that's one reason why Donald
Trump continues to pull so well is
because he is always up front he takes
questions from the media and he he's
really an open book now listen there are
a lot of presidents proceeding President
Biden who had health maladies that you
know people worried would impact whether
they could be president or not and
obviously they did fine but the growing
concern when it comes to President Biden
is whether or not he has the cognitive
or mental ability to have another four
years as commander-in-chief and you know
some of the most common signs of
cognitive decline are losing Direction
you know maybe he just doesn't know
which way to go off stage but also you
know losing words when he's speaking and
forgetting certain events I mean who
could forget last year when he forgot
congresswoman Jackie wolorski had passed
when he was looking for her in the
audience just a few weeks after her
death now none of this confirms a
diagnosis of cognitive decline but there
are certainly questions to be asked and
the Alzheimer's Association they pulled
about all of the primary care physicians
97 percent say that you have to have
cognitive evaluation starting at the age
of 65. yet here we are with President
Biden and in his physical exams we don't
have complete cognitive assessments I
think if they wants the votes from
Americans it will be prudent for the
White House and President Biden to prove
not only his physical fitness but also
his mental Fitness because that seems to
be where the concern is right and you
know Doug we see also there in that list
when it comes to Trump's issues to say
he's over 50 percent you've got DeSantis
I think around 22 percent people
expected more from DeSantis it's it's
interesting that this is what the
campaigns are for right is you find out
what people are made of whether or not
they know who the uyghurs are right you
questions have to be asked there are
debates is there any sign that DeSantis
is having any kind of an impact or that
his numbers might be moving when it
comes to the the Andrews resulted who
would be the nominee
no
there is no sign of him moving indeed
the opposite he seems mired at about 21
or 22. he's going to spend an enormous
amount Tammy in Iowa and New Hampshire
two states where he pulls relatively
better than he does nationally but still
Trails former president Trump by 20
points but these are tough tough margins
to make up both in those two first
primary States and nationally Donald
Trump is the odds on favorite as we sit
here today yeah I think and thank you
all of you for tonight you know and but
of course but just before independence
day it's interesting that you know the
Democrats of course don't want to have
any debate and Lauren I'll give you the
last word here and yet we do have this
huge lineup in the Republican end do you
think all those people being on the
Republican competing for the nomination
is going to have any impact on Trump's
numbers
oh it'll it'll help him I mean every
time a republican jumps into this race
the field gets larger more difficult to
distinguish among and that helps Trump
but look you know I don't think his
numbers have changed for many months now
despite these indictments he's kept this
core level of support it's been in the
50s since before the Stormy Daniels
indictment then the documents indictment
these are people who don't see a clear
alternative and know and love Trump
already it's not necessarily a sign that
his legal troubles are helping and
energizing it's just a sign that he's
the figurehead of the party and they
have not provided an alternative as you
said Ron DeSantis has not turned out to
be that clear front runner right all
right all of you thank you very much
it's going to be an interesting 18
months leading into this at the same
time I I have to say that America he was
kind of elected Trump was on the issue
of a two-tiered system of justice and
now it seems to be playing out in front
of people but we've got a lot of time to
figure it out hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else